à à anh alo cho bạn mà các bạn
hình như ở Mình rất thích cái từ buổi cuối thì ra các bạn online vết
bị hôm trước thì nhớ độc tuần với ông thì mày Ông còn ít lắm cũng như là xem
lại cũng ít chả chẳng xem lại đâu
Cho xem một lần này biết cần gì xem lại đúng không hôm đấy chủ yếu tâm sự và làm tài liệu mà hôm nay thì ra chép cũng thế
chả cần xem lại gì cả
ờ ờ anh alo alo các bạn nghe rõ chưa ạ
Anh vừa mới nói là mày Ô ngon vẻ nhanh tự nhiên lại thấy gia dụng đâu hết rồi
khi cha mẹ ông bấm vào xem có cái gì đặc sắc rồi Thế à
ờ ờ Ừ mình vừa đăng lên cái lý cân của mình
để mà giới thiệu và là mình đang mình
đang dạy cho đẩy mình mình cho mình chia sẻ lên lấy cân cho mấy ông vào Tấn tác
thì đẩy cái bài lên càng tốt nhiều tướng bát tôi tôi không cầu tương tác bởi vì
đây lần đầu tiên tôi đăng bài luôn nhờ tôi đang tôi đang gì với ông mà thì nên
là mấy ông vào tương tác để mà đầy cái bài lên càng tốt Tôi vừa đang cái bài
này Ờ Ờ tôi đang xin các nhà Tuyển dụng gửi
tôi cái gì đi hoặc chia sẻ thêm chia sẻ lan rộng này tệ để gửi gì đi cái gì đi
đấy ẩm đấy để gửi mấy ông mà cái gì đi này tôi chẳng để làm gì cả tôi đi này dành cho Junior mà quên không ghi
a Junior developer
Hình như a star để test nhiều quá nó cũng bị gì đó gì vậy
cho tôi gửi link bài cho mày Ông nhé cũng biết bấm vào đây Chọn đâu Không
phải khi nóng lên cậu
Ê mấy ông thứ nhất là nên có một cái à họ cảm cái trạng có tài khoản trên này
cũng là một cách để nhà tuyển dụng tìm đến ông nhưng mà thời gian nếu mà ông ấy Junior được ra là ít ai quan tâm ông hơn
đúng không Và đặc biệt ông còn mấy hôm ngại vụ để ảnh đại diện mặt mình nữa Nếu như mà nên
có em thấy tuyển dụng trên này tìm kiếm nhiều lắm nó cả chuyện ghi Tháp thế Tôi
từng chỉ mấy ông cái vụ à Tưởng chỉ mấy ông cái vụ ở trên biết hát
người ta tuyển dụng như thế nào nhỉ Mấy nhà Tuyển dụng cũng có thể biết cách
bằng cách ở Tìm ứng cử viên ví dụ là sự ứng cử viên TP này còn tin này sau đó
thì sẽ chọn vào cái advances này Ừ đấy sợ nó sẽ chọn Kiều không quan tâm mày
vipo hai cái thứ mà có tâm cái ở như thế này
ở đó 10 công ty đã chủ yếu Ví dụ ở Hà Nội đấy
đúng không em có lượng người theo dõi bao nhiêu không quan trọng Đấy
Anh Sơn tim Ừ chị ở mấy ông sẽ thấy là tìm kiếm đây
sẽ có chữ P đây mình sẽ xóa TP đi này Ừ nếu đi kia đây pp + rotation + ngôn
ngữ hoặc xóa sự ra đi thì sẽ là tìm kiếm Hà Nội và ngôn ngữ P và tìm kiếm mọi
người mà nó sẽ ra nhiều hơn đó 301 người làm chuyên làm về cái này nó sẽ tìm thôi
Hồi đấy có có nhà tuyển dụng tìm người tôi cũng qua cái ở trên này
Ừ nếu nó xảy ra một loạt này cho tôi biết
các bạn ạ Bạn ấy chị không biết tôi à nhầm anh không yêu tôi tại sao tôi lại
tự nhiên nói anh ấy chị a Chị ở đây vì à Tôi nhớ là có đúng là một bạn nữ cũng
tên là Anh Nguyễn thường hay trả lời ở trên xe close anh không không biết được nhưng mà bạn
ấy trả lời ngôn ngữ khác P là và cũng thấy nó nổ vest bởi vì a đánh
được tất nhiều phết đá bóng vào tương tác đẩy bà này lên bài
này để tìm với cái gì đi mày ông em mày không biết đi rồi ông là mấy cái yêu cầu tuyển dụng đấy thôi tôi từng chia sẻ Tôi
thường nay lưu lại một loạt các di đi để mà để mà mình biết được năng lực mình
đến đâu đấy à Ừ mình phù hợp với công việc và mức
lương như thế nào vân vân vân các công ty Bây giờ đang cần tuyển gì nhưng tôi có sự việc làm rồi và tội Tôi và người
ta gửi cho tôi toàn là JD của sciglio thôi lương hơn 20 củ cơ nên đó họ rất
nhiều đúng không Thế nên là bây giờ là tôi không thể gửi được Đấy do mấy ông
được đúng không Thì bây giờ mới ông phải phải tương bác mà bài kia để bài kia rồi
có vẻ giống như là hỏng Cơ chế pháp giống hỏng Facebook thôi đó làm chỉ là à
Ê bà ấy được đẩy lên thì nhiều người biết đến ở người ta sẽ gửi tôi mà cái j
đi của chun eo thì tôi sẽ lại gửi lại trong bê tông để mấy ông có thể tham
khảo Tôi đã bị Thì ra tôi mà ăn thì không hay lắm ông nào văn tốt hơn thì
bảo tôi tôi sửa lại cái bà đấy tôi cảm thấy văn bài lại không ổn lắm Tôi dọn
Nói miệng hơn ý và thật văn viết Tôi hơi giờ thế nên tôi không ở tán gái được qua
nhắn tin nhé thật được thần thời kiểu cố hẹn bằng được đi uống
cafe đi Nói chuyện trực tiếp với giá được sao dù một phần là do là mình không ăn ảnh nhìn ngoài đời trong nó ít ra ổn
hơn cái ảnh đấy kiểu như thế rất nhiều ông nhỉ thích kiểu bạn gái ở
quá mạnh hơn bởi vì một lúc đấy Nhắn được mấy em nữa à Gọi à Thả lưới à Thả
lưới bắt cá chứ không phải là kiểu câu cốc từng câu từng cả con cá nữa khỏi bắt
cá hai tay nữa thả luôn lưới kiểu thế
ờ ờ chờ đợi tí mình hãy tranh thủ cho các
bạn xem hai cái thứ gà như các bạn thấy tiêu đề hôm nay thì cậu các
bạn cũng nó là chia sẻ chia sẻ Đây là mình sẽ tím mình sẽ chấm chấm một vài
nhóm chẳng biết vào nhóm nào ở nhóm nào mà đã ngắm mà đã làm xong à
Ừ rồi thì gửi bình luận nhé nhắm vào đã gọi dùng tới
nhà đã làm tài liệu thì bình luận để tí mình chấm chấm luôn nhé
à à
anh không có nhắn tin là một khi mẫu Nhắn tin các bạn nữ đồng nghĩa việc các
bạn nữ thì có thể nhắn tin cùng một lúc cho nhiều bạn nữa đi học không giỏi thì mới cảm cũng phải
đi hợp tập chứ ông học ở cho vui à Đúng không ông muốn làm thì cứ sáng nào ông
ông muốn theo ngành này chắc chắn không phải đi thực tập đương nhiên là người ta sẽ người ta cũng không mong đợi cái gì
việc là một người chưa có kinh nghiệm gì đó phải làm làm được luôn đâu nhưng mà tôi tin là trọng sau cái khóa học khóa
cái đồ ăn hay của tôi kiểu gì với ông khẳng định tôi mời ông đi làm cứng cực
sáng là đi làm biết được mình cần phải làm gì làm thế a z chuẩn chỉ rồi bởi vì
công có kinh nghiệm rồi Đồ ăn hay chính là không làm vẫn hay sản phẩm bộ sản
phẩm đầu đón bột là cái sản phẩm để ông biết cốt nhá sản phẩm Thứ hai là sản
phẩm như thực tế rồi thực tế có như thế nào thì cái đồ ăn hay của mấy ông tôi sẽ
phải yêu cầu nó như thế nên là ông làm được đón hay thì chết đàn ông đi làm ông
chẳng thấy bỡ ngỡ gì cả nên là em không phải lo với cái vụ là kìa em chưa có
kinh nghiệm này gì đó khó chẳng qua ông không thể nổ điều Lương Thành sinh ô được thôi Có ông ở đây thì tôi tự tin có
vai ông ở đây cũng học ở trường khác rồi cũng kiểu gọi là điên tí rồi thì mà chưa dám đi thực
tập hoa cà xin được tập nó khói Bởi vì thực ra là bây giờ mấy ông cạnh tranh
thôi cái tầm ngưỡng của mấy ông bây giờ thì đương nhiên là nhiều ông cũng có thế này bắt buộc phải có một sản phẩm thì đó
rồi khoe họ nữa thì cái l** hay chính là cơ hội để mấy ông sẽ có một cái gì đó để khoe với họ là mình đã làm được những gì
mình đã tìm hiểu những cái gì Đúng không mấy ông dễ lên chỉnh rất nhanh sau có độ
ăn hay thế em bé ông Lúc đấy đừng có lo nhiệm vụ là anh đi được tập khó cái gì
đó sẽ được an một đón một thì rất sẵn mấy ông sẽ không thể
lôi gái đi thực tập vì nó chẳng có cái gì cả nó nó hay nó quyết định không ạ ạ
à à à à Ừ đúng Ôi nhóm người dùng hệ thống là
bao gồm cá nhìn chứ ờ ờ năm tháng bảy mươi phần trăm giờ ra
cũng được thì quan trọng và nhớ đẩy lên get để mà tí mình kéo về lẫn cả
làm xong ra làm đến đâu thì mình cứ Chậm qua mình đấy
thì mình xem các bạn cần sửa gì rút kinh nghiệm cho những bạn khác nữa nên là tôi
chỉ cần chấm một vài nhóm tiêu biểu là được rồi anh có cơ cho các bạn xem cái này trước
đã hôm nay ở chia sẻ những các bạn cứ tâm sự giải ra cái gì sẽ trả lời nhé
bài hát thuyết trình bên mỗi admin trang web hiểu gì không Mỗi Vinamilk lại phải thấy trình hết chứ bạn ở bên khách hàng
thì nếu mà giờ xử nghỉ hè mình mình cũng từ ra cũng hiểu có thể hoạt
động các thứ mà tôi không bảo mấy ông mở cốt lên Giải thích từ năm cốt đâu mà cần phải hiểu kỹ lắm Nó bảo mình cần hiểu cơ
chế hoạt động như thế nào đã làm được những gì mình có thể nói được cái đấy mà
Ừ nếu không làm đến admin rồi toàn bộ những cái thêm sửa xóa những cái kiểu xử lý như thế nào Thì ra ông nắm rõ mà
người làm bên emminh rồi cần nắm rõ hơn là sử như ông làm đến khách hàng tự như ông đến admin nghỉ thì nó mới vấn đề đấy
mẹ vợ ông phải kiếm hết Còn bây giờ ông làm bên admin rồi thì cái ông Minh khách
hàng nghỉ thì ông chỉ làm gần như ở làm cho diện Nguyên ăn khách hàng là được hiển thị lên là được mà đúng không còn
sửa xóa gì nữa đâu ờ ờ
anh hơi buồn mà vì à tháng 6 tháng 7 thì mới gần như là gần như là xong đồ ăn hay
mình chưa giác được Mình nghĩ là tầm đấy bởi việc tháng 3 mình nói chung là mình
sẽ cố đoán một này sẽ kết thúc của trong Thắng bụng Tháng 2 này thì tháng 3 mới
bắt đầu học tháng 3 là học Mở với xe vào p về nên là cũng chưa chưa nhảy vào đồ
ăn được luôn mà phải tầm à Cuối tháng 3 ít nhất ở thế thì mình sẽ mình sẽ lại Ạ
cho các bạn đăng ký và lần này mình nghĩa là mình sẽ ở
thì mình sẽ cố làm lại cái vụ đăng ký do nó tử tế hơn đăng ký lần một này có vẻ
các bạn hơi bị to Hằng Nga đại bà sẽ chỉ có bảo vệ một
đầu tôi cho đỡ bằng nhằm đợt 2 mình cảm thấy cứ kiểu gì khó kiểm soát hơn ở chỗ nào Mình sẽ
bà cụ rút kinh nghiệm bởi vì mình có kinh nghiệm mình có kinh nghiệm đi dạy
rồi kinh nghiệm kiểu ghép nhóm đồ án vân vân rồi nhưng mà còn vụ Online này có
nhận được chưa tính đến bởi vì nó thiếu vì yếu tố ràng buộc nên thành ra các bạn thích thì các bạn không làm thì các bạn
nghỉ ngơi Vân thì cái gì nó vẫn thực ra có rất nhiều bạn thì ra có nhiều bạn vẫn
đặt tâm mà nó nhưng mà biến mất thì đương nhiên mình không thể liên hệ được
cũng giống như vai Giả sử tự nhiên bận việc ở chiến trường ạ bây người cơ bản
thì họ vẫn đang học trên trường Họ đang bận đi làm gì đó có rất nhiều Ngày thứ quan trọng hơn
có rất nhiều thứ mà cuộc sống của họ đúng ạ Nên này gà mình khó chứ nếu mà
giống nhở sinh viên của mình thì là mình là thầy họ nên thành ra họ phải nghe mình nó khác
ver2 đồ ăn một thì chắc là bảo vệ sau sau sau các nhóm đón một
lúc đấy mình sẽ báo thời gian hơn bởi vì là có vài nhóm thì có vẻ tương đối tương
đối vẫn đang trong tiến trình làm rồi nhưng có vài nhóm thì mình cứ thấy sai sai cái vì những nhóm đấy
cho đến giờ vẫn đang nghỉ Tết vậy mình nhắn tin tôi có trả lời Nhưng mà
bảo là em chưa làm gì cả ý nghĩa từ từ từ trước Tết à Chưa làm gì
và đến giờ vẫn thế Thế là mình mới đang cân nhắc à sẽ không cho đăng ký được hai nữa
thế hả Mấy ông dùng tiền thì thằng bồ tát tôi tôi nghĩ mà mấy cái chuyện đấy giống như là điển hình là tôi từng cho
các bạn chia sẻ tôi từng cho các bạn xem cái video đấy Đó là để
là còn con người ta đôi khi ở kiểu Khinh những cái thứ gì miễn phí thế nhờ tôi
vẫn cố hướng đến nó miễn phí và cố hướng đến những người nào mà anh hiểu được cái tầm quan trọng của cái
việc miễn phí đấy 10gb Mỗi khi các bạn vượt qua được rồi đấy đồng nghĩa việc các bạn
áo kiểu nắm vững được cái tâm lý là học trong mình cho mẹ học vì tiền hay học vì
cái gì đó họ chuẩn bị tôi hãy gì đó mấy ông mua khi mà phải vượt qua được nhiều
cái bài toán tâm lý hiểu như thế thì mình Ông ấy gọi trả lời được còn mỗi khi
mà Mấy ông vẫn cảm thấy à giả sự như là kẹo hôm nay Lười quá Không học hay ở gì
gì đó thì mấy ông vẫn còn trẻ con quá Tôi dùng từ khẳng định là trẻ con bởi vì ạ
à vì Đúng là sinh viên cũ của tôi nó là như thế xinh nền cũ của tôi là là phải
trưởng thành sớm quá ví dụ là sinh viên Trường tôi là 52 đã phải làm đồ án này
cuối năm hai đã phải đi thực tập này nó còn cảm thấy quá trẻ con và muốn chơi so
với sinh viên đại học ở trường khác sinh viên đại học chứng khác 54 thậm chí năm
Thứ năm mới bắt đầu ra trường đúng rồi nó bắt đầu nghĩ được đi thực tập vì
nó hoàn toàn mơ mộng so với kiểu mày Sinh Viên Chúng tôi Sinh Viên Chúng tôi
mang tiếng à đầu vào thì là tạm Nham nhưng mà đầu ra thì rất là cứng cũng sắp
xe đấy cũng kiểu đó hỏi thì đó thực tế phải trưởng thành rất sớm cho vòng 2 năm
như thế cho nên là nhờ ông vẫn còn trẻ con lắm kẻ gấu người đi làm rồi cũng có trẻ con
luôn gì hả Tôi từng dậy ở B cách a
chính xác học pháp luật trình này các bạn đương nhiên là cần biết một tí tiếng
Anh chuyên ngành để mà đọc tài liệu nếu mà giả sử tiếng Anh tốt lên tí để mà làm
ở mấy công ty nước ngoài cần tốt nhưng mà không cần phải il giao tiếp được trừ khi các bạn hướng đến không phải làm Lập
trình hướng đến kiểu là đi Ví dụ mini list Hôm trước mình nói đi phân tích thị
trường ấy thì cũng đi tiếp xúc khách hàng và cũng nói chuyện với công nghệ đấy cũng làm phán với công nghệ được
Kiểu các thứ thứ nói chuyện nói chuyện nhiều hơn là việc làm việc của về máy
tính à à sơ đồ án sinh viên năm làm 52 ở trường
thấy á Thực ra chính cái thứ mà tôi đang dạy mấy ông này đoán một sẽ là web bán hàng web tin tức Nhưng mà ở ở đây tôi
thấy mấy ông đều đang làm à web bán hàng hết rồi đoán hay sẽ là một đồ án
Nghệ chắc là về sau tôi mới gửi cho mấy ông kiểu những đề tài để vài mẫu để nếu
có thể tham khảo hoặc là béo nghề tự chọn đề tài nhưng mà yêu cầu về toán hệ thực tế nhiệm vụ có nhiều yếu tố nhiệm
vụ đấy Đêm nghiệp vụ tức là gì nữa tiện việc người dùng xử lý những kẻ bay toán
kiểu ví dụ liên quan điều hành liên quan quản lý liên quan đến việc là thống kê
liên quan việc kiểu gì Thì đó nó nhiệm vụ Nghĩa là nó có tự động hỗ trợ cho
người dùng tiện là một cái gì đó chứ không phải là kiểu vừa rồi Giả sử trong
web bán hàng ấy mấy ông thấy à thêm từng sản phẩm thấy mất công anh đúng không thống kê được có mấy ông đôi khi không
có Chẳng đúng không mấy ông thêm sản phẩm theo dõi đơn hàng hay theo dõi
khách hàng là mua hàng mất công đúng không có rất nhiều gái mất công ở đấy để chị vẫn sản bán hàng nhé Mình không có
liên quan việc thống kệ theo dõi xem ở nhân viên mình đã làm cái gì thấy cũng là một cái bài 8 nhiệm vụ đúng không
nhân viên mình đã làm giờ nào cho nó Vân là sửa theo ca gì đó còn thế nữa đấy và
giảm như vụ đấy về sau tôi nói rất nhiều bài giảng nghiệp vụ cho mấy ông nền méo có thể tham khảo hơn
thì mình sẽ dậy mới với dây và Ok mày không dạy về video
video thì là nóng chẳng là gì là gì khó
cả ý video chỉ khiến giản làm cái gạo hướng đối tượng là kết nối cơ sở dữ liệu thì
chỗ khác thôi mình dậy Ok qua để cho mấy bạn hiểu qua về đối tượng bị không dạy
chuyên sâu ở ô bê luôn nhá thì chạy qua thôi Sau đó thì để mà khuya nhảy sạp Adele thì nó sẽ một phen Word và nó có
cả mới xe và ok rồi thì có bạn sẽ nắm rõ hơn à à
Ừ thôi lại Xin chào bạn tranh thủ Xem này nhá
Đi đâu có
gì đâu sutemi sinister iCloud make me Do you
marry your best tool for Spanish Steps and Smart money tips for vlogging every
five tomorrow International is played with the wait out for such file or any
made to travel illustration imade unsupported format
and specialists newberry sinamay to the first to know your computers were born
in only people use with that are you speak English club YouTube beach Club
which Used To You Nothing but most gatesnotes cocain dragon lives for
weight loss people their goods have the money They have really like the wind
River prince ở em khó chịu à Tự nhiên nó hiển thị cái
kia có ghi samshop thì nó sẽ không hiển thị hơn tính it's like you make me feel you to
và mình có cái con bé con sẽ bị suspend mod Money is an important role in every
five tomorrow evening when you're late wants the wait out for such file or any
way you want to want to revolutionize patience is my god unsupported format
and specialists newberry cinemate arafat uno de Sica purinethol were born
aminosalicylate list with that are you speak english Ant Plus basic Craft punch
nutrifort Is nothing but most against Note ok negatively preliminary with the
social workers have the more They have really like you make lasting Friends
English đi Dual Core Switch to threaded cái thì mình tóm gọn lại cho nó ghê
không ạ à à Ừ cái về về bến nước ngoài nhiều hơn bến
nước ngoài họ đang đánh thuế rất nặng vào lần mất lẫn cả là
tôi không nói về chính trị nữa nhưng là ta nói việc đây là làm mất các bạn biết
được bây giờ dầu gội như bà đang bị đánh thuế rất nặng này cũng như là cậu khá như người đang khá khó chịu và nghĩ rằng
là tại sao đình ông ấy một cách giàu lên một cách điên thế thằng Ghét luôn mày thế nó nhiều người bây giờ
rất nhiều người biến ở ngoài đang như thế Tự nhiên tẩy đầu tiên Là lúc đầu thích
thú với ông đấy Sao bây giờ bắt đầu khó chịu vì cảm thấy giống như ở Cậu bị lừa
ấy kia kìa thấy nghĩnh nghĩa là thế tâm lý học mà thấy tự nhiên họ dùng cách
nhanh lên bằng tiền của mình nghĩ là có khi bị lừa kiểu như hệ thì à
Ừ thì ông ấy đang giải thích à có có nhiều người giàu nhưng mà theo hướng tốt
kiểu họ chi tiền để làm những cái thứ gì phi thường hoặc và sáng tạo và có ích mà
anh kia thế và tạm bìa ông nói là mới còn điên nữa còn thì điên rồi Ông này đi ăn ở đây nó là gì Tôi từng nói qua về
cái thiên tài về điên rồi nó họ rất giống nhau à là nghĩ những cái điều mà
người thường không nghĩ nếu mà amos nó Thiên Tài khác và người điên mình thuộc
làm chứng minh được là mình đúng còn tất cả mọi người sai là mình Những thứ phi
thường nóng ạ con người điên không chứng minh được rồi thể hiện ở xã hội sẽ hiểu
vẫn đánh giá họ đấy từ trước khi mà không thành công thì mọi
người đều nhìn thấy ông thất bại Đồ ngoại mà nghĩ rằng ông thất bại cái ông ấy chứng minh họ là không thành công
nhưng mà không được chứng minh theo kiểu đã dạng như trường ngoại binh đến vào
thứ mười mấy ở vẫn chưa nổ vũ nha Thấy ông không thành công được
đấy nhưng mà đại khái nó là như thế đó là kiểu cái quan điểm của ông này nói về một cái
thứ mà tội từng đọc về khoa học mà cái thứ rất là hay không biết mấy ông tìm
hiểu nên khoa học không đó là thơ ca là that la không biết thế là
xe Tesla à Ông là một nhà khoa học thực sự và đã
thiên tài phát minh ra rất nhiều thứ tự thứ vớ lấy con bị hồng đấy Tôi thần tượng trước thì tôi
Hồi đấy tôi đã đọc nhiều cái thứ mình sách linh tinh dùng thủ lĩnh tinh
bằng gì ạ anh ở đấy cho đi sâu làm ở nhà bác học nhà thiên tài xong rồi nhà sát Minh được
không Ừ cảm ơn kia nào đấy thì đi sân Thật ra là một nhà kinh doanh
ở chỗ dựa trên những cái lý tưởng người khắc và phát minh người khác mà kiếm tiền
khi bé mua nhà kiểu nhà danh nhân có thừa thứ Thế mà hồi nãy chẳng hiểu sao về cuốn danh nhân thế giới lại có ngày
sẽ là tôi cứ tin tưởng anh Sơn 5.000 thiên tai xong rồi đồng võ và xã hội rồi
vật nổi lên người vụ tân minh của bóng đèn mà à Ờ Ờ
nói chung à Thế Sơn này còn vùi dập tên A thì em tôi mình khó chịu vụ đấy vui giặt vài cái dòng điện Bạn chỉ nói
bởi vì bởi vì lý do để phát minh giọng không phải không phải phát minh nói chung mà nói chung vào kiểu thấy Tesla
phát minh ra những thứ mà khiến cho các doanh nhân khác sẽ chết và tái la còn
hướng đến làm rất nhiều lại thử miễn phí và to lớn cho xã hội nhưng mà khiến toàn
bộ những cái danh nhân tư bản sẽ có thể bị chết nên thành ra là những cái phát
minh này không thể được ra đời Ừ nếu mà ông tìm hiểu kỹ thì em sẽ biết à
a và và có rất nhiều nhà khoa học thời thời trước nhà hiện tại hơi nước Không
biết bây giờ như thế nào họ khi đang sống bà nội không thể phát minh được rất nhiều thứ
chỉ vì là kiểu các nhà tư bản họ biết họ ám sát vân vân vân đồ kiểu à
anh nói chung là cái này nó liên quan đến bài toán là xã hội mấy ông mấy ông Để ý
kỹ mà em nếu anh ấy ông để ý kĩ là xã hội cái thôi thôi mà đua nhau lên vũ trụ
là thời thành công nhất à về về khoa học đột biến lúc đấy Lúc đấy thì chính phủ
thả cửa để cho các nhà khoa học phát minh và Nghĩ ý tưởng nên mới đồng hoa tự
nhiên kiểu thể lên được vũ trụ Vân hệ sau đó sau cái cuộc cách mạng kiểu đột
biến như thế nhiều nhìn xem cách mạng bây giờ đột biến như thế nào cùng lắm là may mà phải dùng thử mai đó là có cái
đại dịch vừa rồi mình có đột biến về y học Ừ chứ không thì anh vẫn phải dùng được mai nhé bởi vì
không thì sao rồi con người đang giận xem lại chỗ rất lâu và đang mình Các nhà
họ đang ngồi nghĩ là cái gì ngồi Nghị ra máy điện thoại để nhiều pin hơn chơi được game xong ngồi
nghĩ là rất nhiều các thứ thứ để mà kéo y học thì hướng đến phẫu thuật thẩm mỹ
trẻ lậu hơn gì gì đó Không có gì đột biến không có gì Cách mạng đây rồi mai
tự nhiên có thêm ông almus này mới đang nghĩ là rất nhiều cuộc cách mạng có thể dùng từ như thế sẽ làm gì bây giờ
Xã hội bây giờ đang đang chuộng Mà những cái thứ mà nó không phải cái gì đó cũng
đột biến vĩ đại của người ở thời tiết mấy ông xem lại cái meme ý
mày cái miếng nước ngoài kiểu nó không nghĩ cái thời một chị 190 được Hạn Thì
họ nghĩa là tầm 100 năm nữa thì con người dậy đi đĩa bay vân vân Còn bây giờ chỉ đang hiểu ngồi cắm đầu đến điện
thoại điện thoại chơi được game do gọi điện thoại tản nhiệt cái thứ tôi không chê
bai Vì những kẻ đầy mặt ở đó là phát minh rồi Đang cô hướng đến về kiếm tiền và giải trí nhiều hơn kiểu thế
Ê mấy ông xem mày ông nha Anh hello giải trí dân ngồi không à
chích lại toàn những cái vớ vẩn nữa mấy cái nhảm nhí với cái kiểu khiến não mình kiểu vớ vẩn
theo giáp phải dùng tự giác đi Ừ thế thế nên à con người đang bị Tôi
phải dùng từ đang bị và kiềm hãm kìm hãm mọi thứ thì là sáng tạo luôn đã bị giết
chết sáng tạo nữa 300 Đã nói không hả em à tạo gì đột biến
ngồi dịch mà lại em mất thì phận đấy thì mày Ông thấy không Tôi không biết dùng được phát minh đúng không ngờ mất đã còn
những cái ý tưởng Đấy ví dụ là khiến kẹo bây giờ lên ra ngoài tâm vũ trụ này xong
rồi Đang Anh đang giảm dần các ô tô sử dụng bằng
kiểu nhiên liệu nhiên liệu đầy dùng từ nhiên liệu hóa thạch của thẻ xăng dầu đấy đúng không thấy ở
Huế D3 thức ở Hồi trưa mấy ông còn biết là tôi biết em mất từ Cái vụ mà
phủ sóng vệ tinh để mà phát wi-fi miễn phí cả toàn thế giới cơ kiểu như thế
ý nghĩa Họ có những cái ý tưởng và giúp cho tất cả mọi người cùng tiếp cận trí
thức hay cũng như kiểu giúp tất cả mọi người chứ không phải mang tính chất là cặp kiếm tiền ý
và đương nhiên là vẫn phải có kiếm tiền đi kèm để mà có tiền thì mới ra mình những thứ đấy à
Ở đây bây giờ Xã hội bây giờ nó bị chuộng với những ngày ấy như bạn kia đang nói
nghĩa là những cái thứ mà kiểu viễn vong những cái thứ mà kiểu gửi gắm muốn não nhưng mà nó có tí giải trí một tí à Thôi
tôi Thực ra tôi không xem được một cái thứ đấy à ở nhà với xã hội đang hướng đến lấy thật
giả sử Bây giờ tôi đang ngồi nó các triết lý thực ra chỗ không khuyên là tôi không mọi người đổ vào xe mình tôi nhưng
khẳng định là tôi nó một cái chữ gì có nhiều âm sẽ nghe thấy chán sẽ bảo dạy đời với Vân sau đó thích nha Xem những
cái thứ viển vông những người hữu kiểu hở ra một tí ở trên Tik Tok sản
thì nó là sau đây à mà thực là tôi thở ra chưa đọc cuốn
sách này nhưng mà tôi biết được thời đại ý của cuốn sách này ở đó là cái từ rất lâu tôi đọc rồi
Ừ [âm nhạc]
thì theo như mình biết được cái Thì cái này nó đại khái à là xã hội nó sẽ
nó sẽ không phát triển được khi mà không phải là khi mà có nhiều người xấu hơn
người tốt mà chẳng qua là người tốt im lặng và kiểu cho mặc cho người xấu làm
mọi thứ tệ đấy không ý kiến gì cả a Và thậm chí ở người tốt mà không còn
thơ những cái điều đấy những thơ những điều người xấu đã làm không thể biết người giàu đã làm những gì Xã hội nó sẽ
đi xuống thứ nhất là mấy ông mà nhớ là mấy không phải tự tốt bản thân mình lên này Thứ hai là ở
em có cái khái niệm tôi phải giờ tôi thích khái niệm châm biếm nó kiểu phê phán nên cài kiểu
ở những cái xấu xung quanh tôi khẳng định có rất nhiều người ở đây sẽ chọn mục đích là kiểu
không nói gì Kệ nó đi Nó Vân ý đến chính là bạn bè với ông ngoại ông
không dám nói những cái điều kiểu nói thẳng vào mặt nó những cái điều rồi dễ là mày đang làm sai gì đó
cho tôi Tôi dám nói hỏng cả thằng bạn thân rồi còn gửi hàng vào mặt Nếu nó làm
gì đó sai đấy như tôi có cái sai thì tôi cũng nhận và cũng mong nó nói thẳng mặt
tôi rồi sửa Ừ Nhưng nhớ là phải cải thiện những cái
đấy xung quanh ngờ từ người thân mình ngã ngồi thậm chí là như tội từng nói là
là là thầy người thầy của tôi hồi trước tôi từng bảo đó là thầy còn dám nói
thẳng mà cả người lạ niệu giờ xử kiểu nơi không được phép hút thuốc hạ của ông
nào đây dám nói thẳng một ông ở đó lớn tuổi mình Ê thằng con trai lớn rồi Mình ngon Ừ ông
trung niên là gì nhiều con vật ông là anh ơi Không được hút thuốc đây hai chú
ơi không phải vẽ hút thuốc đây lợn phí à chú ơi Không được đổ rác ở đây các kiểu thứ này là vừa xả rác rồi ông ông thử
nói đấy xem dám nói không ạ
Thơm cùng nó bây giờ ra cái đấy nó khó rất nhiều yếu tố như ý nhờ có cách để
cải thiện cái việc về ít nhất là mấy ông có thể ngồi nói trên mạng được nhưng mà phải nói khéo giữ mãi bây giờ mạnh nó
cũng gần như là một cái gì đó một cái cộng đồng rồi mà Nhưng tôi tin là mấy
ông vẫn thờ điều đấy số tiền hình giống ở trong nhóm nhiều tìm cái tiên à Ê hồi trước Và tôi vẫn
chỉ ở thành viên nhưng mấy ông thôi Nhưng tôi thấy có gì sai Tôi sẽ góp ý hoặc là tôi sẽ báo cáo lại cho bằng cái
chị nào ạ nhiều âm thấy sai xây lò đi nhưng mà bây giờ đúng nhóm về cơ bản
nhóm này đã có khá nhiều ông văn minh kiểu và góp ý hơn
các thành phần tập nhau vẫn có nhớ khẳng định thành phần gặp nhau vẫn có rất nhiều chắc chắn rồi không nhóm là thoát
được bởi vì đông mà nhưng mà có nhiều văn minh và góp Vì hơn và báo cáo nhiều
hơn thành ra bây giờ chất lượng bình luận hãy đợi chất lượng mọi thứ có vẻ vẫn thường Nam tương tương đối ổn Tôi
đang Lấy một ví dụ điển hình về một cái cộng đồng ở nó nó ngon cộng lớn nào rõ còn rất nhiều nhóm khác tôi vào rồi
không dám Long Bình luận vì nó tạm nhanh tới hợp tam rồi con Vân ừ nóng thấy đúng không ạ
khi gặp người cục xúc quá thì tôi nãy thầy tôi nữa thì tôi dạy võ mà Thì tôi
học võ rồi cùng có đi dạy võ cho trẻ con cơ hay đấy còn dạy ảo thuật nữa Tôi từng nói qua
chứ nhỉ Thấy nói chuyện dí dỏm hài hước lắm Hay cho xem video đi Nói cho xem
video để mấy ông học cách nói chuyện nhé thì anh cho quân sự tên rồi
Em hãy tên là Tuấn ảo thuật thử xem còn nhé á
Anh Tuấn Mg không không phải Tuấn 3G nhé
Ừ tôi vì vậy như thế Tuấn bao giờ này Nội fast
Nội hơn có thể thấy gần đây cũng khá nổi rồi
Ông Hà Công Tuấn này
anh ấy thường anh diễn ảo thuật trên đường phố nào này
34 quất 14.000 Nếu có thấy nội trên Tik Tok nhiều hơn nếu nhìn trong 24 ý đúng
không thôi mở Tik Tok lên mấy trăm nghìn Nếu anh sẽ thấy khác à mà quan trọng nào thầy hãy đi diễn
đường phố và nói chuyện rất là hài nói chuyện được với trẻ con hay phết xe đẩy tiêu Cho xem cái video
mọi người tôi lên hàng thích Toán Hồ Chí Minh này ông nhé tranh thủ quảng cáo thay mình
cho cơ thể không hiểu sao nó cứ lên cái cái này đầu tiên tôi gọi tao nhé á
anh không được nghỉ em không có pin rồi đi rồi
30 Tết được ạ Công Tuấn
này à à à
à à ừ ừ ở đây 486.000 để mấy ông thấy 4.000 ở
đây nó cái gì không Đừng đừng tin về bên kia pin cái này để 7 triệu à Thích nhỉ à
Ừ anh ấy nổi trên thì tóc hơn trong những Tik Tok bây giờ khiến người ta dễ
nổi hơn
anh phải làm thế nào để được lần này người theo dõi rất là nó phải có gì đấy đúng không Không phải giác ra nhé
Để tôi tìm một cái video áo kiểu dạy ở ngoài đường phố thật để
cho mấy ông xem hài nha hình
[âm nhạc] ảnh lạ nhất
[âm nhạc]
[âm nhạc] quả bóng à
em không học Visa là không nói nhiều có bây giờ nói cho 22 so với cậu còn trêu
lại à Mày em nhỏ buồn cười cực là hiển nhiên
123 I a14 nhé
nghe và luôn nhé
[âm nhạc]
thì bắt đầu từ 4 4 4
1 2 3 à
Ừ tôi không kiếm cái video này tôi không tìm thấy video rồi nói chuyện cả hai đâu
rồi ở những bé Ông thấy Xem thử mình sẽ biết à
Anh Hai nói chuyện với trẻ con được Nếu mà anh ấy cũng sẵn sàng thái độ kiểu mặt
sẽ thái độ hoàn toàn khác luôn Nếu mà với ai đó mà cậu ấy như tôi đã nói hiểu là sự xả rác ra đường anh ấy Nhắc ngay
này hoặc là anh gửi mua thuốc anh sẽ nhắc Ở đây có trẻ con rồi đây đông người
anh chú đừng hút thuốc cho thứ II
Ừ thôi tôi không chia sẻ ở đây ngồi xem video tôi Tôi xin
phép tâm sự nói cái này rồi dậy nhá lên tám mấy người được cả đống đi vào
xem ở Thuận Đông Hằng à đi tìm kiếm Khổng Minh Forever With You
Test ok rồi
okay decide idea What the weather That is not lend your deck list box
striving to your currency of compassion
just went well now now Where will forever
Why of his intelligence piccoli smart smart affair with
bath room soup Is All I see is what we couldn't have
something and cancel it onto their visits to Door to use of
squares search for Mac Tìm kiếm file Forever cho tôi phim sex xin phép dịch
lại anh ấy thì đầu tiên thì khi hai người đang phỏng vấn nhau ngủ ngon là
à mà kéo nếu mà bạn được chọn bất tử đúng không Thì bạn có đồng ý không không
mất gì cả chúng ta đều bất từ không được Sợ chết ngoài à à
Ừ nếu tôi không biết mấy ông nghĩ nha thì tôi sẽ là tôi sẽ chọn không ngớt à
Nói về mặt bi quan chưa đi ngoan có nhiều cái lắm cái con giờ sự như này tự
như là sự những loại tận thế không chơi hết mình không còn sống ông kiểu ông không chết không sẽ lơ lửng
ở trong vũ trụ lại suốt đời một mình tệ vãi để cái big one
Nếu là sử không nhân loại mãi sống đi mãi sống dưới tiếp xúc rất nhiều loại
người đúng không Nhưng vẫn là không Bởi vì a như như đã trong cái phim toy Tôi
không biết nói Ông chưa Nhưng mà trong phim cho có một câu rất hay đó là thần hàng ghen tị chúng ta Vì chúng ta
à à khi chúng ta có thể chết còn họ không nên thành ra chúng ta có
có quãng thời gian đẹp nhất cuộc đời của Thanh Xuân là cái gì gì đó nữa
ạ và chúng ta kiểu dạng mà còn sẽ biết được mình sẽ chết đấy nên sẽ sẽ
kiểu tận hưởng mọi khoảnh khắc có thể rồi Vân Vân trân trọng mọi kỷ niệm gì đó
nếu ở sự mà bất tử để ông phải trân trọng với đi tất cả mọi thứ không được tiếp xúc trước thì ông chẳng thấy nhìn
lần ấy ít nói chuyện gì hết á Ừ ông đang nó một cái đi qua nữa Bất tử là
kiểu lại phải quen với việc à chia tay với mọi thứ ngon mọi thứ dễ rời xa mình
còn mình thì mình thì mãi còn đấy đúng không Lại một cái vì con ăn nữa
mà một cái mà bên tay để cập nhiều nữa không biết quan niệm mình không Có không
đó là lần tay họ sợ chết rồi bị họ sẽ họ sợ bị bị quên thấy nó có đề cập trong
video này thì ông ấy bảo là
là kiểu ông này thì không Không ông ấy sợ mình
chưa làm được một cái gì đó có ích cho xã hội hơn là sợ sợ cái đau hay sợ cái
chết những Thế sợ cái chết vô nghĩa nhiều như thế thôi cũng thấy tôi cũng cũng mong mình sẽ làm được cái gì đó
Hình như tôi đã nói để lại một cái gì đó di sản của mình từ tự gì sạc
nó có ích một tí chứ không nên hiểu trên một cách nhạt nhẽo viện vong gì đó mà
chưa làm bằng cái gì cả Vì sao đến bây giờ tôi đã tôi cảm thấy tôi đã có ích tương đối có ích Không
nhằm hạn nhưng mà nó vẫn chưa là một cái gì một cái gì
thành tựu gì to lớn cả không muốn kiểu không phải muốn tất cả mọi người cùng biết đến anh gì gì đó
có thể thành tựu của tôi Không phải tất cả không phải là nhiều người biết đến cũng được bản thân mình bạn hơn mình cảm
thấy là nó càng già nó có ý nghĩa được đúng không ạ
Lê Thái Trân trọng chú ý em là sao nhỉ
thì alo về bị Hơi lan man quá đưa tiền trả lời câu hỏi này bởi vì những buổi
sau cho tôi tổng hợp câu hỏi chợ hôm nay qua bên lập trình làm nữa Cái này ở hung
hôm ngày hôm qua thấy tôi nói là công ty tôi dữ liệu xử
lý nó rất lớn nên là cách để một xử lý một cái gì đó đưa phải cân nhắc làm bìa
trong câu truy vấn dữ liệu lấy dữ liệu ra dữ liệu bây giờ của một bạn của tôi
lên 44 triệu thức là nó có dở quá tải so với máy Có sao thì mai que như tôi đã
từng nói đó là nó xử lý rất là tương đối khả năng mượt ở trong phạm vi 100.000 đổ xuống nhưng nếu không cần nháy nách thì
cả không cần những nét về mày câu truy vấn bởi vì nó tốc độ không ảnh hưởng lắm không không thay đổi nhiều nhưng 44
triệu thì nó ảnh hưởng rất nhiều khi mà các bạn đánh sidec mà quả xử lý Nói như
nào đấy để tôi sẽ thử ví dụ trong mấy ông một cái à à
ở tuổi ví dụ một cái nhé Ừ cái cái này là cái hình tròn tôi chia
sẻ những kinh nghiệm thực tế nhé hi vọng vì ông có nhớ rồi Nếu nhiều hơn thì tôi
không biết nhưng hi vọng vì ông nhớ Bởi vì ạ vì sau thì mấy ông đi làm không ít người
nói cái điều này trông á Tôi tôi phải tự trải nghiệm thực tế đấy ngon người có
kinh nghiệm trải nghiệm thực tế như thế
du lịch sử website này của tôi đi thật sự là bây giờ một cái mạnh bất kỳ là sự
bán sản phẩm đi đúng không ở bảng thủy thường ai có cột đầu cột a
cột máy cột mã sản phẩm nó sẽ là khóa chính rồi đúng không Thì mình Nếu mình
có ae nào cả mã sản phẩm này thì nó sẽ luôn nhanh hơn whey họ những cái thằng khác không ạ lại mình thử nhé
và đương nhiên là bây giờ là dữ liệu đăng ít nên là mình không quen với bất cứ cái gì nó nó cũng thế thôi mà cũng
nhanh thôi mã sản phẩm này bằng bột chẳng hạn
anh vẫn nhanh tất cả đều rất là nhanh nó đều bảo đây tốn rất là ít giây rồi Vân
thì nhưng mà tôi không đề cập vụ đề đây mà tôi sẽ có thêm chữ explain ở đây để
giải thích giải thích rồi câu truy vấn này để các bạn xem được cậu trình và ngay bản chất là sự diệt qua những cái
gì nó sẽ tốn như thế nào Tại nó diệt qua 100 Bạn ghi này đây Ở đâu không nó giết
qua một bản ghi thôi Cái này tôi không nhớ Có gì tôi không ngờ lắm nhiều cái nhá Nhưng tôi có đọc qua biết cái này
cái á cái key này và smokey và key này vào chỉ là mình đã có sử dụng cái nek có
sử dụng kiểu lông mày và có sử dụng cái đấy thì nó sẽ rất là nhanh do việc là nó nó là không có để tôi thử ví dụ và cả
nhé em thật sự là tên tên sáng phải như thế này nếu mật khẩu
lại này thì mong sẽ xảy ra ở đây vì nó không không có cái kia là nôn này
mà không thấy không có key nào nó đang phải lấy theo cột này và và cái này
không được đánh Index thấy ra ở rất là chậm Bây giờ tôi sẽ cho mấy ông xem thêm một cột nữa cổ đánh nick này
ở cổ đại như có này lên đấy à của anh đúng không Thì nó sẽ như à
Anh không quan tâm thì việc nó nó trả về kết quả gì nhé tôi bằng 1 thì có khi không trả lời cái quả mình quan tâm điều
đấy đâu đúng không Mình xem việc là nó ở đây
Ừ cái đẳng Y đất nhớ về không được à nho quét anh bằng một có vẻ là rượu
say say đây biểu tượng intek này nó vẫn vấn đề em có về được th2 có đánh knak Bảo sao lại vừa
possible kia ở đây có anh đợi mình một tí Ô thế mình bị ấn hành ở đây có đánh đấy
đi khi tới đây kỹ biểu tượng ngài sai thằng thằng TP Em yêu làn điệu lắm vì tượng
sai cái này không được làm gì đấy nhé Ê thằng thằng này được đánh đấy rồi đấy
phải đánh chắc chắn được ảnh lên đất này để ông xem xuống dưới này biết này đất này tên sản phẩm đáng yêu thích rồi
Ừ thế thử một cái chắc chắn nhưng mà đánh đấy Cái số lượng đi ừ ừ
anh nói tôi nhầm đấy tên sản phẩm máy đánh đấy còn nên nó mới hiển thị flexible kiểu kia còn nếu mà không có
thì nó trống như này hoàn toàn này là thế này mới câu truy vấn nó rất là chậm này không phải duyệt qua tất cả này mà
nó sẽ chậm hơn rất nhiều nhưng mà cái cái về Winx này nó vẫn không chỉ dừng lại đấy như tôi đã nói
cái nó lên con thứ tự xử lý một lần nếu mà ông học lập trình với ông biết về cái
khái niệm E nóng lạnh ho là một trong hai cái đó đúng là được đúng hoặc một cái bên trái đúng mà vẫn phải đúng còn
kệ em đúng không ạ Và cả hai cái bên đều đúng ạ thì a ho hen này nó cũng đều như nhau vì cái
túc về cái việc xử lý là luôn ưu tiên từ trái trước rồi xong lại cứ việc từ trái
sang phải thế nên là giả sử là em giả sử có trường hợp giống như vừa rồi
mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ có hai cái một cái là tên sản phẩm đi
bằng một kho số lượng bằng 1 hoặc lại em cũng được như này khiến miếng sẽ thấy à
nó sẽ diệt qua thằng này diệt qua thằng anh hơn nó kiểm tra hết vào ngày thằng
này sai gái em lập tức là nó không chạy đến Hà luôn mà mà vì thằng này nó được
bánh nhưng Jack nên hành gia tốc độ xử lý của nó nhanh rất là nhanh nó không quan tâm thằng này đáng được đá như đấy
không Ê mày mày không nhỉ Tôi không thay đổi đáng lên đấy coi là nó sự rất nhanh và
nó điều kiểm tra một loa hết là sửa chắc chắn không có tên sản phẩm bằng một nên gần như là tốc độ xử lý rất là nhanh
nó không cần phải kiểm tra số lượng bằng một luôn Nếu không hiểu gì tôi không này
rất là nhanh luôn còn nếu mà giờ xử ông ngược lại là ông lại cho số lượng bằng
một trước rồi tên sản phẩm sau như thế này thì là sao Thì cái này nó sẽ bị giảm
hiệu năng của vì số lượng kiểm số lượng ở đây nó không có đánh đấy ngân hàng nó kiểm tra cái này nó bị chậm sau đó thì
nó kiểm tra Bên này bên này nhanh thì không nói cái này nhanh quá muộn rồi rõ ra là hai cái hàng này nó em nó cùng cấp
nghĩa là kiểm tra thằng nào trước cũng được mà đúng không to thường gặp Nói thế nghĩa là mình sẽ ưu tiên cái nào mà nó
phản nó Khánh khái niệm của lập trình nó sẽ thêm khái niệm nữa là là hit Ế
là là trả về sớm trả về thành công hay thất bại sớm cách nhanh để chạy đề mà để
đỡ phải xử lý lâu mấy ông thấy có trường hợp gì có sai hay chuẩn có đúng Có thể
kiểm tra luôn thì mới ông lên trả về kết quả luôn sớm chứ không phải là kiểm tra
hết từ đầu đến cuối rồi Mày không phải trả về giống như trong trường hợp này rõ ràng là rõ ra là cái này nó xử lý nhanh
hôn thì mình cần ưu tiên kiểm tra nó trước Nếu nghỉ được không ạ
có liên quan bên lập trình tư duy khá nhiều cái này không ai quan hoa toán mày
không không thể bảo cái này thuật toán rồi nhé a bánh Lac tất cả đám chỉ là là
cột Đấy cần đánh mục lục để mà xử lý nhanh hơn thôi Nếu ẩn này đánh Iraq này
không ẩn ở đây có câu lệnh cho mày đọc Còn nếu mà em muốn hiểu rõ đêm nữa Bây
giờ anh khó mà giải thích kiểu lại từ đầu anh em có thể tra có video anh dậy và Iraq nhá
lỗi à Ừ nếu mà dữ liệu tách lớn thì không đáng
nói Index đấu ngọt mấy ông chỉ đánh lên đất được Nói chung mà cái cột nào dữ
liệu ít bị nổ ra tranh ai còn đánh mình Đất này dự lớn thiếu nhiên rồi không không khóm à kiểu đánh bộc lộ cũng khó
lắm ạ Ừ Ok chị ạ ạ
a cho đến đâu nhỉ À bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm
tra một vài nhóm nhá Ê mày nhóm ở Bác nào có nhóm nào đã làm
tài liệu rồi Nhà nước mình à anh
alo có nhóm mà đã làm tài liệu rồi nhóm của ông chốc kia là nhóm 7 đúng không á
không Tôi nhầm nhóm A nhóm ấy nhỉ để xem mười mấy quá
ở trong Củi khô lại có mất tích cực anh em Em đẩy tài liệu lên chưa nhỉ để
anh kéo cô về luôn
à à Ừ nó nhóm 21
mẹ tôi thở ra tôi thích rất thích số 21 tại một phần là tôi thích cả
Ừ đấy cộng lại hãy xinh rồi đấy ạ
à à Làm sao để xem không biết đó có thông
báo là đã lắp bếp được update những thằng nào không
vì nó không thông báo đây vậy
à à tự học Thiết Kiều quá học thiết kế thiết kế
với giao diện ấy thì chỉ giao diện tôi chịu để tối về xin hạ viện đâu còn nếu mà Học
để mà học web thì tôi đang dậy đây ạ
cho dù thế ừ nóng năm bạn thứ mấy cái nhóm này còn
chưa chắc à em chưa Chắc là ở bạn làm tài liệu cho đôi khi họ chỉ cập nhật cốt cơ nhóm 21
bao giờ tôi có tạm chữa nhỏ mai mốt nữa nhé Nhóm nào cần chữa thì có thể bình luận tôi nhé
Ừ Kệ xem tài liệu nhằm 21
đề tài liệu phân tích à À không đùa nữa Nói chuẩn đấy Tôi đang
định bảo mày ông không nên đặt tên nó tài liệu phân tích
ở nhà cũng được hoặc là mấy ông để luôn đón một cũng được mà em còn cái đồ ăn
hai nữa shop bán áo con gà không liên kết Tắt nhé không
Về đi tao không bảo làm đến việc nên viết đầy đủ tên tôi nhưng nhỉ À không nên đi biệt danh không nên ghi tắt thì
gà cho trong chuyên nghiệp Ý chị và mấy cái mà trong trong dấu ngoặc
nhọn này Mấy ông không biết điều gì mà không Tạm xóa đi nhé Nghe có vẻ Hình như là mục lục rồi không
biết được là một lúc khoai chưa chị xem Ê mày cái đoạn này chắc là triệu gì đấy Ok
Để đây đã anh nói chung là tôi đang hướng đến mấy
ông chuyên nghiệp mà đó nên là mấy ông cần phải từ đầu đến cuối trong chuyên nghiệp thì mấy ông thích máy in ra được
mà đi làm ngày làm rõ xem lại được ờ ne suis chữ f viết hoa nhé nó sửa cái
lỗi chính tả luôn đấy cho nên ghi đỡ ghi phiên bản rồi mấy ông
lên thống nhất Là tất cả những người đang sau cũng nên ghi phiên bạn và cái này nên em tôi xuống dòng nữa cũng được tách ra đây rồi html5 là sẽ ba này số
máy quen là gì nãy
ở nhóm người dùng hệ thống trọn đời này đúng rồi lên được lấy đấy nhóm người
dùng đấy thiếu nó khách hàng cho tài khoản khách hàng có tài khoản nữa 4 loại đấy
ờ ờ Ừ ok này tuổi ở tiền nhìn này trông vẻ
hơi khó chịu nhưng cái này cái này nó không phải là cái mục mục lớn này hoàn toàn mình thì để ghi ngay được còn nếu
vài mục lớn thì mới ông đẩy xuống hẳn xuống dòng dưới nhìn ở tiện được anh giống như mấy mục lớn của Nga không
khi phân tích Chức năng ở trạm xóa cái này đi nhé
Ừ cái này xe tải lại k a
ở Hà Nội tình cảm
hi vọng các bạn này không hợp lệ không hợp lệ thì à
ở đâu sao em xin vào nút Đăng nhẹ à à
Em à sao lại bạn này đang bảo là và bếp bằng ra sweep
Ừ thế thì ở đây Chuẩn là nếu mà làm bằng da Speed thì sẽ là à
Anh ở shop mypham À nghĩa là cái đẩy đẩy Phóng đi gì đó sau đó thì bên bác nên xử
lý nữa Ngoan Em có biết bà đang nó ra Speed 20
Ê mày không cần sống tầng không ạ Ừ
anh như bạn đấy có cái ở đây hiển thị nhưng mà do cái vuốt tôi phiên bản cũ ấy không không không ra được cái bài chắc
là đây có hai cái ngon bạn đây đang để tôi thấy bạn phải có cái á ừ ừ
Ở đây có
ừ ừ khi đăng ký Ê mày không lưu ý thỉnh thoảng bị lỗi
này thì mới ông phải chỉnh lại phát minh nhé mắt định bát tinh Hồi đấy Ở tội được
phép trận mấy ông cũng chỉ được phép là like spicy ngay thôi
anh nghe này
có nhiều cái này làm đâu Nhà tôi tôi có để cập ở trong nhà trong cái hướng dẫn làm tài liệu đấy
anh biết thừa cái xuống chậm khó chịu nha Ừ để đăng ký các khóa đào tạo cho Ken à
trong xịn đấy à ở trên đó là phân tích của bạn này thôi không đề cập sâu nữa vì trong bạn ở chú
thích về tương đối đưa rồi có rất nhiều phết
à à à à
Ừ cái thỉnh thoảng bị giãn là như thế này thì mấy ông nên mở cái Google này mấy ông kéo thì chị nó hơi bị khó chịu
một tí thì dùng từ khó chịu gì À đấy mày
Ông thấy nó kêu bị ngay không Vì thế nên là mấy ông phải cắn chỉnh khi
mà làm xong hết rồi mẹ mình lên cắn chỉ nhé Em làm biếng có thể à
giữ giữ phím shift để cùng chỉnh tất cả cùng một lúc cũng được
anh trai tự nhiên bị bị giãn à e ko lại được ở nhà đúng
ở thủ đô quan hệ thực thể này hồ sơ cơ sở điện này
Ê mấy ông nên để thêm một cái lưu ý này nữa nhé Trông thấy ở đây thứ nhất là cái
chữ này béo không Mày không phải chính lại nó bằng cỡ chữ là một nhá thứ hai đó là
mấy ông có thể ý là ở trên này mà thôi kẻo anh chuyện với ông sẽ
Ừ thế này 36 3.11 khi để thống nhất Kiểu như thế này và nên là thống nhất kiểu
ngay thì nó sẽ là kiểu cách cách viết ở trong cái cái phân tích này nó viết kiểu gì
viết tôi không quan tâm thì ông ở đây lúc mì Ông mấy ông ở đoạn này lên như
này bạn này có thể 12 rồi A B rồi y2 à Tưởng tượng gì cũng được nhưng phải
thống nhất là ở dưới cũng sẽ phải như thế cũng phải như thế là một tương tự là
ở trên này mấy ông thấy em nó là 3.1 3.2 3.2.1 như này rồi cái chỗ này ít Nghiêm
thì ở dưới nó phải thế cỡ chữ chỗ mày như thế nào ở dưới mày Thế chỗ này là in thảm nó cỡ kiểu như nào đó dưới vẫn phải
thế để ngoạn Ngày Thử cá đến lùi vào cấp này thằng
hai phải lôi vào nhìn nó rõ hơn này ờ ạ và ở dưới này Tại sao tôi để cập thế
rồi dễ này bạn đấy Bị lùi cái này vào này và bạn đấy bên A sẽ sai nó phải 4.1
Nếu mà bạn thống nhất ở trên như thế nào ở dưới vẫn phải thế nếu mem nhìn và menu rồi em sẽ thấy ngon menu đang kêu 2.1
các thứ tự nhiên 4 vào Nghệ An thì đã sai rồi a&b Tower hướng dẫn mấy ông làm tài liệu
như viết một cuốn sách luôn này sách nó mấy ông nghe từ chuẩn sách giáo khoa học
Nghĩa sách giáo khoa Nó kiểu nó cố nó để từng cái đánh mục lục 2 đánh những cái
kiểu thứ tự như này nó rất là rất là kiểu cho thuốc tỉ mỉ nó rất là
chuẩn đấy người ông sẽ phải như thế đó Ê mấy ông mở lại quyển sách giáo khoa để
kỹ lại mà xem Âm nhạc giúp kinh nghiệm và cái này nhá tụi em nói chung là tất cả mấy ông ấy
chồng mà nói mỗi bạn này đâu ạ à Tôi đang cố dậy mấy ông cả tính tình
nghị nữa làm thấy liệu phải tìm hiểu chứ
anh nhìn hơi bị khó chịu khi nó bị kiểu xuống ngay nhỉ Thôi tạm chấp nhận bỏ qua
anh khó khăn Hiệp được nhà Nhảy cứ một bảng một trang thì bà trông mẹ hơi chậm
quá Ừ cái naina nên chụp cái đoạn mà có nối
nhá Có nối nối khoa ngoại anh ấn vào đây rồi chọn design Chắc là
bạn này không biết nổi chưa hoặc không thể không biết mở cái nổi lên Mày không
ấn vào cái này ở đâu nhỉ Đúng rồi ấn cái này xong rồi Gì à Đúng ở đâu nhỉ đây có
nhiều cái thứ nhất là ấn vào đây này để mà nó cắm theo ô cho cho đẹp này
ở bảng xếp hạng nhau hơn này mở cái mở cái nối với sự mở nối rồi à
Ừ cái du lịch sử rồi
ở đâu không dùng cái này tự nhiên tôi quên hết Bơ một cái đi
Ừ hai cái này là tội chưa lỗi nha em
a b để cho xe máy phát nhanh xem Hà Nội chưa
à vì tôi nhớ có cái Ẩn màn hiển thị nối
em chưa lỗi bảo sao cứ nói khách hàng
xin lỗi đấy nếu mà không nổi này đôi khi nó sẽ không bị lỗi cái răng buộc khó Ngoại
đúng không ạ mã sản phẩm tra lạ có này
họ đậu xanh đi học tôi xóa hết sử cái à
mã sản phẩm đi nghe được
ừ ừ ừ ừ
bí mật lỗi em à à
à à anh vẫn lỗi Hình như là liên quan đến
kiểu dữ liệu của cột về rồi
à mà sản phẩm làm gì có dữ liệu đâu nhỉ
Ừ anh sẽ nhớ mã nhà sản xuất ở đây tôi để là kiểu cha này
à À bảo sao anh nghe đổi một cái bất kỳ đi
em mãi mãi này ra được
anh nói đùa nói được rồi ấn vào đây tả lại sang đây
anh có nhớ không lầm thường là sẽ hiển thị cái nối lên mà mình thường là mình phải tắt cái nồi đi
mã sản phẩm đây ở đó bình thường sẽ hiển thị nổi lên tôi
nhớ mà lại như này Và nếu người tắt đi đây đây mày tắt nè
em vừa rồi không hiểu đi cái này vừa rồi trang của tôi làm gì có lỗi đâu bảo sao
Ừ đúng nhỉ Mà tôi không để cái này nhá vừa Tôi nhớ không có cái này tắt máy ông xem nhé
Ừ nếu có cái này có xóa gì vậy
anh lại ngồi xóa mấy ông lại mua xem
em bỏ anh xin lỗi mày không Chắc là do là bây giờ thì bật lên là tôi
không để ý Có bật lên như là do không có lối đi gà không hiển thị lên thì chỗ nào chú ý nghĩa là bình thường là mày ông sẽ
phải nối và nó luôn được mở sẵn rồi mày mày không chỉ cần vào chụp thôi Bấm
fullscreen này mà chụp nha Đây là kiểu chụp trong mức cơ bản thôi tôi thấy nhiều ông còn biết cái chụp trong đẹp
hơn dùng không cụ khác để chụp đẹp hơn
em sắp xếp hiện nay cũng cũng cũng được dùng thực cũng được mà vì khi mà các bạn
nối vào trong nó lau nhàng hơn thì các bạn sẽ phải sắp xếp sao cho nhìn lại rõ cái nồi nữa thôi trang web admin hứa sao
rồi trang web thì nên có cả khách hàng nữa mà thiếu này ạ khách hàng trang chủ
vào sẽ đăng nhập đăng xuất là quản lý do hàng bờ Vân Kết luận đang cả phân công
công việc bạn sẽ là ok đấy Vừa rồi tôi có nói qua việc các bạn cần cần phải làm
gì để một cái tài liệu các bạn trong nó nó giống như một cái quyển mà các bạn về
sau các bạn sẽ phải tự ngưỡng mộ bạn thân mình là mình đã làm rất là cho Suốt đó là cầu kỳ Ừ để mà ngày này năm sau
không phải ngày này năm sau nữa phía sau cho con sóc con cháu xem để Ngạn đã mình
đã cậu cố gắng vì một cái như thế nào dựa theo đúng một cái ông chẳng quen
biết gì qua mạng hướng dẫn ngu khóa miễn phí đúng không để mà mình
vẫn cố gắng đi nó để làm ra một cái gì đó sau đó thật chính mình làm theo được ngành này thì đây sẽ là những cái viên
gạch đầu tiên của các bạn thì viên gạch này cần phải chắc chắn một tí đúng không ạ Phải Kiểu nó phải ổn một tí chứ không
hiểu làm kiểu dạng mà thôi Ra làm trang không ai đọc đâu vật liệu không thích
mấy ông giống kiện sinh viên tôi cứ in hẳn A mấy ông mang về nhà làm về sau sẽ
tự cảm thấy kia mình sẽ cố gắng làm bị các xịn đúng không
Cho tôi xem từ cái quyển đón một của tôi so với quyển đón hay rồi Thậm chí luôn
ba tôi thấy khác biệt lắm nhưng mà tính tôi tôi bảo tình tôi được cái nó hơi tìm
mỉ và cầu toàn nên thành ra là ngày từ đoán một Tôi đã không xa lỗi trên thảo nguyên nhân như thế và chỉnh căn căn
chỉnh kéo lùi đầu dòng hay từng cây à
đã từng nuôi đầu dòng này hay từng cỡ chữ phông chữ ở tôi thống nhất thống
nhất hết rồi vì sao rồi Tôi chỉnh lại cụ phá a trình đại câu chữ các thứ thử nữa
thôi cách trình bày nữa thôi em heo Thực ra buổi hôm nay thì gặp chỉ
có nói qua tâm sự chia sẻ và nói qua thì thôi á môi quyền quý
em chưa Chưa nên phát bội rồi nhé Ờ ờ nói gì nhỉ à
anh nói lại thêm một lần nữa về cái vụ à khi bảo vệ đồ án Nga hình thứ bảy bảo vệ
đồ án ở dễ đúng không bảo vệ Thử ở xe
máy mấy nhóm được tôi duyệt làm bảo vệ đợt một thứ bảy cố
thứ nhất là sao bữa này thấy tài liệu của người này bảo tôi tôi chấm này tôi
không thể cũng chẳng biết là nhóm mà đã làm tài liệu gì gì đó thì mình để biết
đường và giấm nữa Thứ hai là à
cho nên có mặt vào hôm thứ thứ 7 thứ 7 kiểu hôm ấy cô trốn đó nhé
tin tức là trốn thì tôi bảo thiệt mày ông thôi Nhưng mấy cũng phải chuẩn bị cái Hữu để
tránh việc là hôm nay chuẩn bị đi cả đúng Hoàng Vân thì hôm nay được nhưng phải có passport rồi và cốt nên phải có
một phải miếng phải ghét hết cốt rồi để chỉ thuyết trình trên một máy thôi chứ
không về đâu mái bạn này có mấy khách hàng nhái bạn này bên 5inch chẳng biết là nó không đặt hàng rồi đúng không Nếu
không lên là kiểu thuyết trình ở hết Trên một máy thôi cả hai máy đều có PowerPoint để mà cùng
ờ ờ Thực ra là không chỉ cần một máy rồi đúng rồi Chỉ cần port 1 máy rồi sử dụng
màn hình một máy hết ế Ừ thứ bảy bảo vệ khử đã bây giờ mày mới
biết à Thế bây giờ rồi thứ bảy những cái Ngó mà được duyệt đợt 1 thì tôi sẽ ra neun vậy và Vậy thử đấy
đã đun mới nhá không ở nhóm và tự nguyện cũng được nó tự
nguyện lên đầu được để mà tăng tinh thần tự ti Nó các bạn thì cái PowerPoint các
bạn sẽ có tất cả những cái mục này đây lý do chọn đề tài này công nghệ áp dụng
này đối tượng sử dụng này chức năng tôi mới lượng này Phân tích Chức năng không cần đề cập ở trong slide
trừ khi ra nổi bật rất ngon nước khác biệt những nhóm khác giữa các bọt các
bạn tốn rất nhiều thời gian cho nó các bạn thế có trong thời lại được nên chỉ một vài cái thôi sôi động thể sơ đồ cơ
sở liệu A và hướng mở rộng Tôi không biết tôi còn cái mẫu cho mày không xem không
những mẫu giày gà không còn đâu nhưng mà tôi hệ cho ông xem cái đồ ăn 1 của tôi
tới tôi hình như cho mày không xem cái đồ ăn Mua của tôi rồi của tôi không phải mẫu nhá đồ ăn Mua của tội khá tệ anh ạ
nhưng tôi tôi sẽ tự nhận xét để đợi tí
từ mạng à à Ừ hình như tôi cho mày không xem một lần
rồi thì thôi chọn đôi giày lời khuyên nhá rồi khuya này mới không biết PowerPoint Từ nay về sau này đó là một
trang không nên Kệ ông nghe khái niệm 77
chưa Đó là một dòng không quá 7 chữ và một slide không quá 7 dòng để ông ạ
ý nghĩa làm chị ít chữ thôi mấy ông đừng có cậu cũng đông dữ ra ngoài rồi mấy ông
nhìn vào cái xe like ngồi đập không ý chữ để cho người ta phải phải để ý ông
nó nói gì thế này thì có ý chính rồi Nếu nhìn và ít được đọc đúng không ạ mày không thuyết trình có khi là tôi dậy ở
mình kỹ năng thuyết trình nữa à À thế à của tôi thế này còn nhiều trước đây đấy tôi bảo tự nên đám bạn thân mày
mà thứ hai là để xem đối tượng anh không Nó phải nhớ rằng công nghệ áp
dụng hội đối tượng đâu à ở nhà phân tích nhu cầu khách hàng này
Phân tích Chức năng này Phân tích đối tượng này tiếp theo là rồi từng tính năng từng
tính năng thôi tiếp theo là Xô kẻ rồi khỏe không chưa đến ờ
Ừ ừ nếu mà không phân tích Chức năng thì có thể nhảy sâu phải cũng được cho nên thống nhất nào để tiếng Anh thì
toàn bộ tiếng Anh tiếng Việt toàn bộ tiếng Việt không phải chọn lựa đạt được mỗi như tôi đâu nhé Nếu mà dài quá đưa tách làm 2 nhiều Hồi
đấy tôi phân tích chuyên sâu thôi còn phân tích các bạn nhắn một cái cha nuôi vội
sau đó cơ sở liệu cơ sở dữ liệu cho các bạn không cần liệt kê toàn bộ bạn như thế này các bạn chỉ cần có người ảnh
tổng quát cái giống như ảnh vừa nãy em được em ạ à
Ừ thế thôi Sau đó thì đến hướng mở rộng ống rộng xong rồi Kết luận được kết luận
rồi hướng dẫn thì chuẩn hơn đấy kết luận là đã làm được những cái gì chưa có phải
nói một câu chung chung như ai kiểu ạ đã tìm hiểu được quà Cái gì còn thiếu sót
cái gì em còn thiếu sót khác với cái hướng mở rộng theo hướng mở rộng là những cái
tính năng nâng cao còn còn thì có sóc phải ăn Thiện rồi kiểu chữ tôi yêu phần nào phần nào còn chưa làm được gì gì đó
nó khác hướng mở rộng khác nữa Ừ cái đại khái là cái slide các bạn nên
có để mà không thấy chương trình Và tôi thực ra là đã từng tốn khá nhiều thời gian ngồi làm Slide không biết mấy hôm
có tìm Mị như tôi không anh em không có nhiều thời gian thế và tôi thường từng
khá tiếc vì cái vụ đó ra nếu không cần lại tạo hiệu ứng slide đâu Thật mà ông
cứ hiển thị đã thôi tôi từng Hồi đấy ngồi mất hơn một tiếng nữa ngồi thì làm
đồ các hiệu ứng kéo thì lần lượt từng cái từng cái theo mình nói rồi xong rồi sẽ like chuyển động theo slide này nhỉ
xanh sẽ like kia chuyển động nó cứ các thầy cô không quan tâm nên hạnh và cũng chẳng cần nên Hãy ra các bạn có thể bỏ
qua tất cả hiệu ứng gần như là toàn các bạn làm sang Word chuẩn chỉnh rồi thì Ừ
thì các bạn sẽ chỉ cần lấy cái tiêu đề đã một vài ý chính của từng cái mục
trong Word để mày Ông ôm mà sẽ ra được rồi đấy Kiểu kiện như thế
em không hiểu gì tao à Còn cái vấn đề môi trang web này này tức là sao và mấy ông sẽ khi mà phân
tích xong cái này này khi phân tích xong này ông nói qua hết toàn bộ với mấy cái này rồi mấy ông sẽ tắt cái slide đi rồi
đi mô để Ngoan cái quy trình bảo vệ đồ án là như thế Nếu thế thì cái này phải
lên xuống cuối nhỉ ở không mà ông Hòa tùy mày không phải nói hứa hướng mở rộng sau khi ông để mua
trang web cũng được tôi biết được là để biết được là cái hướng mở rộng của ông có đúng hay không và kết luận ông có
đúng hay không được như thế để ghi thêm anh nhá Đợi thì
kết luận Này dỗi giận Okay đây nghĩa là mấy ông sẽ nói hết toàn bộ
khoản trên này sau đó thì mới ông Tám Plus like đi mình không nói để mô trang
web sau đó thì ở ở ở anh quay lại slide nói về hướng mở rộng
và kết luận để tôi xem thực sự mà ông đánh giá bản thân ông đánh giá các trang web của ông đã là nó gọi chuẩn hay không
mấy ông ấy lại hơi ảo tưởng quá à à
ờ ờ đồ ăn hay thì các bạn sẽ có phê góp Vario thôi mình không dậy các bạn thêm
Facebook về biên nhận giá ship bao vì mình cũng chưa nắm chắc là lắm còn đón một thì nói TP
thế hả bạn Nguyên ngày chưa ngủ à quen dần đi home tôi một phần là tôi được làm
việc tại nhà cũng như thời gian tôi thoải mái Nên hay tối cứ dậy tôi ngồi máy tính cứ thấy cái thể tôi không có
khái niệm ngày đêm này và tôi mấy ngày nay tôi gì ngày nào cũng ngồi cốt hơn
mười mấy tiếng số 11 12 tiếng để chết
anh Thắng làm đây chắc phải đến tháng tư tháng tư mình cũng bắt đầu dậy lao leo tháng 3 mình mới con ăn Dậy MBC show bim
à à
ờ ờ Thôi bữa mày chắc tại mình kết thúc thì thôi mày Ông còn thắc mắc gì thì cứ bình
luận và hoa nhắn tin thôi sau nhé Ừ ok Xin chào bạn nhé
khi ngồi làm tài liệu hội nắm tay đi à